Hey guys, Pete here. This will be my
better Call Saul season 5 episode 10
recap and review. I've got to mention
that this will be spoilery contains
spoilers for everything that's happened
in better Call Saul through season 5 and
also cover events through the entire run
of Breaking Bad. if you're not caught up
then this is your chance to turn away.
The season 5 finale was titled "Something
Unforgivable" and it brought what was
arguably the best season of Better Call
Saul to a close. In doing that it felt
more like a setup for the ending rather
than an end. And in this case it worked
well, but I wouldn't say it was
satisfying. Then again I'm not sure it
would have felt satisfying if any of the
major characters whose endings we don't
know came to an end either. Overall I
didn't want it to end but it did. I want
answers,
but as Mike would say I'm asking for
information I can't have. I like where we
are, but I don't like the uncertainty of
not knowing when we'll actually get to
see the final season. What I do know is
Kim and Jimmy have switched places from
where we left them at the end of season
4. In that closing scene Kim was surprised
to learn that Jimmy had fooled everyone
including her with his passionate speech
about the law and his brother in his
reinstatement hearing. We watch him walk
down the hall emboldened by all the
recent events. Stopping to turn with a
smile to say, "it's all good man." As he
goes we see this shot of Kim as the
camera pulls away where she's looking
lost and alone. To make it worse Jimmy
seems to be clueless about how his
future wife feels in that moment. In the
season 5 finale the tables are turned.
Jimmy is still recovering from the
shootout in the desert and the opening
of the episode he finally comes clean
about what actually happened. the
couple decide to head to a fancy hotel
to distance themselves from the scene of
Lalo's unexpected drop in. Jimmy feels
relieved after Mike tells him that Lalo
will be killed, but he's far from
emboldened this time around. when she
comes up with the plan to destroy
Howard's career so that they can force
Sandpiper to settle, it's Kim who seems
to be clueless about where her
partners head is at. the shows co-creator
Peter Gould who directed and co-wrote
this episode with Ariel Levine really
leaned into this connection between
these two scenes. when Jimmy was walking
away he turned and pointed in Kim's
direction with two fingers. when Kim
walks away she turns and makes a finger
gun gesture shooting in Jimmy's
direction. this time we watched the
camera pull away from Jimmy and he's the
one who looks lost and alone as he sits
on the bed trying to wrap his head
around what he just heard. the turnaround
is surprising, but not completely out of
the blue. what I really loved about the
way it played out inside the episode was
watching the progression. when they first
came to the hotel we could tell that
they were dealing with what happened in
different ways. Kim was up early in the
morning ready to hit the courthouse.
Jimmy tries to stop her from going and
we get the sense that he just wants to
hide. we can look at their screen time
together and apart as an examination of
how each of them reacts to this
traumatic experience that they just went
through together.
Kim loads up on cases at the public
defender's office before she runs into
Howard. Jimmy goes looking for Mike to
get answers about how worried they
should be. I think the most telling
moment for Kim is her laughing in
Howard's face after she learns about the
bowling balls and prostitutes, it all
sounds like small potatoes to a person
who just talked her way out of a
showdown with a cartel boss. for Jimmy
it's when we see his anger drop as he
says, "if anything happens to her," to Mike.
to be fair Jimmy probably should be in a
worse spot considering his experience in
the desert, but by the time they come
back together at the hotel we understand
that their heads are in different places.
Slippin' Jimmy can't help himself when
talk turns to a scam though. things start
out innocently enough with Kim joking
about shaving Howard's head and of
course Jimmy knows a much better way to
go about it. we see the progression kick
in from there. things snowball and as the
tables turn to Jimmy trying to put on
the brakes it all feels inevitable. even
though she's telling herself she's doing
it for the right reasons, and the cost is
only a career setback for one lawyer, we
know that
final price will probably be well beyond
whatever worst case scenario she might
be thinking. we are in the Breaking Bad
universe after all, and that's a place
where choices come with consequences.
even in my initial reaction of having
just watched the episode there are so
many different possibilities flying
around in my mind. questions like, "did Kim
just break bad?" "was this always about Kim
Breaking Bad?" "is there something in Kim's
history that we don't know about where
she's already done this sort of thing?"
where does that leave Jimmy? will he feel
responsible? will he try to protect her?
will a feeling of responsibility cause
him to intervene and try to derail their
plans in a way to protect her? it opens a
lot of doors without really negating the
ideas we've already had about where
things are heading. I'll come back to
that at the end because we still have
the whole cartel story to talk about.
we learned that after leaving the
apartment Lalo and Nacho did go straight
to the border and watch them arrive at
Lalo's compound. he's welcomed by his
staff and I instantly feared for all of
their lives.
going into this episode I had a hard
time imagining any of the major
characters dying, but when the camera
lingered on his cook outside of Lalo's
home it just felt like she was a goner.
that worked well to set up the ending
and the trip to Don Eladio's with
Nacho being able to impress him really
had me thinking Lalo might die.
the trip to Don Eladio's really
scratched the Breaking Bad references
itch. this time around we watched Lalo
score some points for the Salamanca
family over Gus who came up a little bit
short.
Lalo gifts Eladio a Magnum PI style
Ferrari with a big box of cash in the
"frunk". Nacho is able to win him over in
their conversation which is capped off
with a "salud". this of course is the title
of the Breaking Bad episode where Gus
finally gets his revenge against Eladio
and the other cartel bosses. back at
Lalo's compound we see Gus's
assassination plot play out.
Nacho got a call instructing him to open
the back gate. when he goes to do that
Lalo is sitting by the fire drinking a
beer.
Nacho has to think
fast and makes things work by causing a
diversion with a frying pan of oil on
the stove when he goes inside to get
more to drink. Lalo has to do some fast
thinking of his own when the assassins
show up outside the kitchen. with the
help of a human shield he makes his way
to his tunnel that he has in his
bathroom. my favorite part of this was
him stopping just as he was about to
close it. we see that he comes up with
this plan to come back in that moment. he
knows that they'll try to follow him and
uses this to his advantage when he
sneaks back into the house.
Nacho is able to get away but he ends up
by himself since all the assassins are
taken out. in a great shot Lalo pulls
the mask off the guy he burned with the
oil and tells him to call his bosses to
tell them that the job is done. he looks
over and sees the decanter that Nacho
had brought out before he gets up. then
he sees the dead body of his favorite
cook as he's walking away. as he goes it
looks like the rage is building up
inside him as the episode and the season
come to a close. and that's where we
leave things. besides that last sequence
it was a mostly subdued episode in
comparison to the wild ride that
episodes six through nine were, but it's
not like things slowed down. let's look
at where all the characters are. Gus, and
by extension Mike, will surely be in a
tough spot after this. Lalo will know it
was Gus that sent these guys and he's
just won favor with Don Eladio. Gus's
best option will be to try to pin it on
Nacho, but he may run into some
resistance from Mike. for Nacho himself
he's gonna have to figure out a way to
stay alive after fleeing the compound in
the short term he may be able to get
away perhaps the assassins left a driver
or at least their vehicles behind but
what options does he have after that as
for Lalo beyond the people inside his
house he didn't lose much his biggest
problem is that Gus is in the US and
he's wanted there for murder and jumping
bail he'll have to figure out how to
deal with Nacho but his position isn't
weakened that much on the other side of
things Kim appears to be set on going
after Howard she's convinced herself
that the good she can do with the money
is worth
whatever harm they have to hand out in
the process of getting it Howard looks
poised to play a much bigger role next
season and I'm not sure he's ready for
the fight that he's in for Jimmy and Kim
are a pretty formidable duo when they
start working together
when Jimmy mentioned the episode title
and saying that it would take something
unforgivable to get them to turn on
Howard he quickly followed that up by
saying he doesn't deserve that which is
true Howard has his problems he's not
the greatest human being but it's coming
to Kim wasn't as much about him as she
made it out to be
Howard's concern that Jimmy needs help
is actually true Howard thinks he needs
help and he actually does need help
and Howard delivered one of the best
lines of the episode when he said, "you
know who really knew Jimmy? Chuck" and for
my money it's not just because this is a
great way to shut down the conversation
but because it highlights Kim's
inability to see the situation
objectively Kim got duped by Jimmy in
that Mesa Verde meeting and she decided
to solve the problem by getting married
everything we've seen her do since then
has been to prove to herself that this
was the right decision in their private
life she only has the choice of doubling
down or walking away and to this point
we've seen no hints at her leaving I
don't want to sound sour on Kim I loved
the character of Kim and the betrayal by
Rhea Seehorn. Rhea Seehorn needs to win
an Emmy this year as far as I'm
concerned I'm not saying that she
doesn't care for Jimmy or that they
shouldn't have gotten together really
I'm just saying that her decision to be
all-in with Jimmy coupled with her
personality and sense of wanting to
solve her problems herself has me
worried I'm not sure if she's emboldened
by getting through the lalo scare if
she's maybe already been down this road
before or if she's just not able to see
the slippery slope in front of her right
this moment I do know that I've always
been worried about how Jimmy was going
to bring her down and now I'm worried
that she's on the way to doing that
herself we spent all this time wondering
when Jimmy would become the guy we knew
from Breaking Bad and at the end of the
season he looks like he's just along for
the ride at this point that in itself
may not be satisfying but how we got to
this
they surely has been and the questions
that raises are a lot of fun to think
about it's impossible to say for sure
how things are gonna play out
we got Kim and Lalo both picking up a
head of steam heading towards the finish
line
Jimmy has his concerns with Kim's plans
although he'll likely jump in with both
feet once the scam gets going it'll be
interesting to see what Lalo expects him
to do and how much enthusiasm he brings
along with him we're at the end for now
but it feels more like a pause hopefully
it won't take two years until we get to
find out how it ends but even in the
worst case scenario it'll probably be
worth the wait there were so many great
small details in this episode I'm just
gonna point out - when she's making the
sundae at first Jimmy says he wants
everything and then he asks her to take
out the mint chip which it was the same
flavor he had in the ice cream cone when
Nacho came to pick him up to introduce
him to Lalo for the first time another
one almost feels like a troll from the
writers there's been all this discussion
about the fact that Jimmy still
terrified of Lalo when we first meet him
in Breaking Bad that's made people think
that he might still be alive later in
the series Gus tells Hector that the
Salamanca name dies with him indicating
that Lalo is dead at the end of this
episode Lalo made the assassin called
Gus which at least in the moment would
probably believe him so the water gets
even muddier because it turns out now
that Gus could actually be wrong
whenever he thinks he's dead I do think
this was the best season of better call
Saul to date season three had been my
favorite and I think this topped it
because the two sides of the story
finally came together I loved Chuck as a
character and missed him once he was
gone but I feel like the focus on
bringing Kim and Lalo front and center
really pays off of course it's all built
on the character work that they've been
doing in the lead up so on some level it
just feels like they're getting better
as they go along the writing acting and
filmmaking are all incredibly good at
the moment like I said in my la love
video I do believe bringing his
character in at the end of season 4
brought life back into the cartel side
of the story and with him bringing Kim
into that side it
feels like we're approaching an end to
the series and even though the focus
wasn't on Jimmy at the end it was still
a great season for the character he got
married he became a friend of the cartel
and he even drank some of his own pee in
some ways they've only been putting off
the inevitable with him but I can't
really think of a glaring example of
something that was not essential that
happened this season Bob Odenkirk has
always been great and I think he's
outdone himself in this season my quick
take after finishing the episode was
that Jimmy will do something to sabotage
their plans to take down Howard that
could save Kim from going all the way
down but their relationship would likely
fall apart if that were the case then
there'd still be hope that they could be
reunited in the Gene timeline or at
least get some closure and I think I
need to end it there I will be making
another better call Saul video this week
probably a questions video like the big
questions we have at the end of season 5
I may also do a season 5 recap for the
whole thing so that we have that to go
back and watch when the new season comes
out I do want to hear what your
questions are in the comments what you
thought about the finale what you
thought about the season and where you
think things are going please like this
video if you enjoyed it please subscribe
to my channel if you haven't already
thanks for watching I will talk to you
soon